Вибачте, командир.
Сандрі Кротевич телефонує її брат,
перший заступник командира полку "Азов", Богдан Кротевич.
Чоловік повернувся в Україну 21-го вересня,
під час найбільшого обміну військовополоненими
від початку повномасштабного вторгнення РФ.
Понад три місяці він перебував у полоні у Москві.
Щойно повернувшись, Кротевич одразу долучився до справ,
якими опікувалася його сестра,
і вже почав займатися планами
щодо повернення решти українських бійців.
Ми себе, наприклад, наша асоціація,
лише підсилила цим обміном і поверненням керівників.
Тому що саме керівники… Це їхні бійці, вони за них будуть
боротися так, як не буде боротися ніхто,
і вони вже це роблять. Вони не відпочивають.
Вони не лікуються. Вони вже входять в роботу і займаються цим.
Причина такого поспіху - в полоні досі перебувають сотні
захисників Маріуполя, і їхній стан,
враховуючи нелюдські умови утримання,
з кожним днем погіршується.
Мені дуже не сподобались заголовки,
що всі захисники "Азовсталі" повернулися.
Вибачте. Людей було дуже багато, майже дві тисячі людей.
Ви кажете, що повернулися лише двісті чоловік,
і ви кажете про всіх захисників "Азовсталі"?
Так, це дуже велика подія.
Це дуже щаслива подія, особливо для нас,
у кого вже повернулися хлопці.
Але має бути якась повага до інших сімей.
Коли 22 вересня вся країна стежила за поверненням захисників "Азовсталі",
Євген Сухарніков щосекунди зупиняв онлайн-трансляцію,
аби роздивитися кожен кадр.
За кілька годин чоловік зрозумів,
що новини для його родини будуть невтішними.
Десь близько другої години ми з дружиною не спали.
Дивилися, чекали, сподівалися.
З'явився офіційний список близько десь другої години ночі.
Ми побачили, що там немає прізвища.
Відповідно зрозуміли, що в цей транш
не потрапила моя дитина.
Після теракту в Оленівці Сухарніков знайшов відео,
де на одну мить промайнув його син.
За словами Євгена, боєць був більше "схожим на тінь",
ніж на людину - настільки він схуд.
Після останнього обміну з Євгеном звʼязалися побратими сина,
які вже повернулися в Україну.
Військові підтвердили батькові жахливі умови утримання.
Він живий. Сказали, що їх годують.
Жахливо, але годують.
Один хлопець таку фразу сказав, що їх почали краще годувати.
Стали давати більше хліба трішки.
У цьому... Навіть по цій зміні "меню" можна зрозуміти,
наскільки у них там умови.
Принаймні вони не помирають з голоду.
Це для мене, як для батька, хороша новина.
Після почутих розповідей бійців, які повернулися,
мама іншого "азовця" в полоні, Тетяна,
ще більше переживає за свого сина.
Зокрема, про його стан після ймовірного катування голодом.
Він у нас при житті нормальному шістдесят два був.
То зараз тридцять? Тому що у однієї мами син 105 кг був,
зараз 57. Ну, значить 62 і 30...
Це взагалі голодомор як голодомор, у людей кістки і шкіра.
Тетяна не знає, де перебуває її син.
Вона не мала жодної звістки про нього з моменту
його виходу з "Азовсталі". Жінка вірить, що її син живий,
і що він повернеться додому.
Однак непокоїться, що і без того погані
умови утримання взимку стануть нестерпними.
Дуже вірю, хай тільки трішки швидше роблять.
Бо зима йде, холодно. Опалення сто відсотків там немає.
Будуть мерзнути, хворіти.
В СІЗО в Донецьку, кажуть, там клопи, воші, блохи...
На думку рідних, документувати й надавати розголос
нестерпним умовам перебування бранців
мали би міжнародні організації, зокрема, "Червоний хрест".
Цю думку поділяє і дружина "азовця" в полоні Арсенія Федосюка, Юлія.
Жінка регулярно спілкується з представниками інших держав
і міжнародних організацій. Останні, на її думку,
показують низьку ефективність.
Я розумію, що росіяни їх не пускають,
і вони не підуть штурмувати цю Оленівку. Але…
Є проблеми зі списками.
"Червоний хрест" - взагалі його завданням єдиним,
по суті, яке вони визнають, було записати
всіх військовополонених, зробити список. Цього немає.
Зокрема, коли захисники "Азовсталі" виходили у полон,
Юлії повідомили, що її чоловіка серед бійців немає.
Це виявилося неправдою.
Однак тепер, на думку Федосюк, час наголошувати на поверненні
всіх бійців додому, а не на покращенні їхніх умов
за сприяння "Червоного хреста".
Ми дуже сподіваємося, що це відбудеться.
Що їх допустять, але на такому фундаментальному рівні,
звісно, питання обміну важливіше, тобто,
щоб просто їх витягати звідти, тому що про умови,
про допуск, ми говорили три місяці.
Вже годі про це говорити, вже треба їх всіх обмінювати.
Євген Сухарніков взагалі побоюється, що нещодавнє повернення
215 захисників Маріуполя, зокрема командування,
приглушить хвилю підтримки українських полонених.
На думку чоловіка, повернення бійців - це перемога,
однак зупинятися в жодному разі не можна.
Влада, у першу чергу, має розуміти, що ці обіцянки,
я десь там у "Фейсбуці" побачив, що ось,
Зеленський - молодець, обіцяв - виконав. Насправді ні.
Тобто дякуємо. Виконав частково, але це лише там,
не знаю, може, десять відсотків від того, що справді треба зробити.
За даними віцепрем'єрки Ірини Верещук,
Росія утримує у полоні ще 2,5 тисячі українців.
Правозахисники називають більші цифри, зокрема 7-8 тисяч осіб.
Серед полонених - за даними полку "Азов",
близько восьмисот "азовців".
Натомість Україна утримує значно більше російських військовополонених.
Однак і в оглядачів, і в родичів українських бійців
складається враження, що для росіян
їхні рядові солдати не мають великого значення.
А отже, на наступні обміни вірогідно
більше впливатимуть політичні домовленості,
аніж бажання Кремля "не кинути своїх".